lors de notre second débat au lendemain
d'un 1er mai relativement peu
mobilisateur quelle marge de manoeuvre
pour les réformes sociales du président
la république retraite rsa sous
condition allocation distribuer à la
source les chantiers sont nombreux
jeunes attendus priait
les manifestations du 1er mai ont sonné
comme un avertissement emmanuel macron
si le président veut entamer de grands
chantiers sociaux les syndicats
l'attendent au tournant notamment au
sujet des retraites emmanuel macron
voudrait porter l'âge légal de départ à
64 ou 65 ans hors de question pour
certains syndicats comme fo c'est une
réforme qui est absolument malvenue nous
sommes prêts effectivement si nous ne
sommes pas entendus à manifester et y
compris s'il le faut à aller à la grève
mais j'espère que on n'aura pas besoin
d'en arriver là et que on va tenir
compte de ce que nous disons et des
raisons pour lesquelles nous sommes
opposés à cette mesure de recul de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite pendant la
campagne emmanuel macron avait esquissé
les contours d'un autre chantier
conditionné le versement du rsa à une
activité de 15 à 20 heures par semaine
là encore des syndicats comme la cftc
promettent de rester vigilant pas
forcément opposé à l'idée d'une
contrepartie à cette aide cyril
chabanier réclame des clarifications
quant aux projets de l'exécutif
si on nous dit que les personnes qui
touchent le rsa doit faire 20 heures de
travail en contrepartie pour l'obtenir
ça n'a pas de sens si on est capable de
donner 20 heures de travail à quelqu'un
à ce moment le mais plus au rsa il faut
lui donne un salaire qui est une
contrepartie qui est un qui est un
devoir à tout droit ça nous choque pas à
la cftc mais ça doit être sûr de la de
l'insertion sur de la réinsertion sur de
la formation plus consensuel emmanuel
macron entend attribuer les aides
sociales à la source à tous les
bénéficiaires ce nouveau mécanisme
permettrait d'automatiser le versement
de certaines aides comme les apl la
prime d'activité ou encore le rsa avec
le double objectif de simplifier les
démarches administratives
tout en luttant contre la fraude sociale
les réformes sociales des mâcon sa marge
de manoeuvre on en débat tout de suite
avec emmanuelle anizon bonsoir vous êtes
grand reporter à l'obs olivier babeau
bonsoir économiste président de
l'institut sapiens pablo pino vivien
rond soit responsable éditorial de la
revue regards et matthieu croissandeau
et au respect tic à mes côtés est
évidemment dans cette dernière partie
d'émission on vient de voir avec ce
reportage emmanuelle anizon comment les
réformes surtout qu'à ce qu'ils avaient
dans les réformes sociales potentiel de
du président macro cette idée de marge
de manoeuvre comment vous l'analysez
vous en fonction de la grogne sociale du
climat social du pays aujourd'hui
la grogne sociale on a encore vu pour ce
lors de ce 1er mai et elle est quand
même même si elle pas énormément de
monde dans la rue elle est là
il y à il ya une violence latente que
l'on sent il y à une défiance vis-à-vis
du politique on connaît et qui ne sera
pas réglée par deux trois réformes et
surtout qui risque d'être réveillée très
vite à la moindre réforme donc je pense
que dans sa marge de manoeuvre va y
avoir beaucoup dans son attitude dans sa
façon de proposer ces réformes dans sa
façon d'écouter la rue et de prendre en
compte le message qu'on lui transmet de
la base ce qui n'a pas su faire autant
des gilets jaunes est ce qu'il va devoir
sans doute beaucoup amélioré ces
prochains mois oui avec une difficulté
et on va parler des retraites évidemment
et de du rsa des réformes sociales mais
olivier babeau on peut pas démarrer ce
débat sans intégrer dans l'équation
économique la question de l'inflation en
avril les prix ont augmenté de près de
5% par rapport à avril
2021 4,8 pour cent c'est le chiffre
précis c'est peut-être là le premier
chantier social si j'ose dire des
manades macron oui on peut dire que
peut-être que le plus grand risque
aujourd'hui c'est moi les réformes qui
va faire que la situation est la façon
dont elle va évoluer on est en train
d'entrer dans une situation terrible de
stagflation c'est à dire que vous avez
une baisse de la consommation liée à
l'inflation qui fait baisser la
croissance une croissance nulle au
premier semestre on est à
0,1 donc c'est là qu'elle a quasiment
nulle du coup on est en train de revoir
les prévisions pour 2022 au départ on
était plutôt sur 4 % gouvernement table
sur 4% on est plutôt du côté de l'insee
à 2,8 on se demande si ça va pas être
beaucoup moins on voit vraiment que
l'effet de l'énergie l'augmentation de
l'énergie peut être assez fort encore
plus sur nos voisins européens mais nous
très très fort et ça les conséquences
elles sont terribles parce que vous
voyez bien que l'inflation faux
souvenirs c'est un panier moyen à dire
que c'est fait sur une consommation
moyenne et c'est un peu comme le
français moyen c'est que ça n'existe pas
c'est qu'on est tous un peu ailleurs et
il ya des gens pour qui l'inflation est
beaucoup plus dur c'est à dire que ils
ont une grande partie de leurs de leur
coût qui est du coût des placements qui
est des coûts de logement à tous et ils
sont très très touché par l'augmentation
notamment du prix de l'énergie et sa
roue souvent la phrase et gilet jaune
c'est l'étincelle malheureusement qui
pourrait évidemment potentiellement
mettre le feu une forme de mouvement
social est absolument
pablo pino vivien cela la difficulté
dans cette démonstration s'est
finalement posé ici on se place du côté
de 2 des manuels macron c'est que les
leviers dont il dispose sont pas
forcément efficace contre la guerre en
ukraine la flambée des prix de l'énergie
exactement c'est le gros problème c'est
que il ne dispose pas de levier sur tous
les paramètres à la fois sur l'inflation
la hausse du coût de l'énergie etc donc
c'est vrai que on peut pas non plus
faire porter tous les maux de la terre à
la politique d' emmanuel macron et
l'inscription de la france dans un
système mondialisé dans le système
européen
le fait qu'on soit qu'on soit lié à
l'euro c'est bien sûr que là on est
tributaire de politique plus générale
j'aimerais revenir sur la première
question que vous avez vous avez posé
sur les marche de manoeuvre mais pour
avoir des marges de manoeuvre il faut
avoir un programme clair puisque gens
sinon en fait moi ce dont j'ai
l'impression c'est que les différentes
réformes dont vous avez parlé sont des
réformes potentiel à la retraite à 65
ans le rsa et suse et moi et moi j'ai
suivi la campagne présidentielle à la
fois avant le premier tour et dans
l'entre-deux tours et je ne suis pas
certain en fait que emmanuel macron
veuille vraiment aller jusqu'au bout de
ces deux sur c'est sur ces deux points
on a vu que les ministres il y avait pas
mal de cafouillage je sais toujours pas
si le rsa ce qu'ils entendent par quinze
ou vingt heures de tout ce à quoi me
travaille service civil je sais mais bon
on ne sait pas ce que c'est donc pour
l'instant j'ai l'impression que oui pour
ceux qui pourraient faire en fait d'ici
dix il était peut-être pendant les six
premiers mois c'est effectivement essayé
de composer en fait avec ce qu'il
pourrait essayer d'ailleurs c'est ce que
vous disiez ce qui pourrait essayer
d'aller sentir en fait ce que ce que ce
que veulent les français et les
françaises qui seraient capables
d'accepter je ne sais pas si elle macron
est capable de faire ça de son goût
d'aimer c'est ce qu'ils devraient faire
ensuite à partir de cela à partir de ce
qu'il sent en fait c'est une prendre le
pouls de la france faire des
propositions qui ne qu'ils ne bloquent
pas complètement toute toute notre
économie
olivier babeau cette croissance nulle la
au premier trimestre c'est la même chose
au niveau donc en france c'est 0,1 pour
cent entre janvier et mars au niveau
européen c'est la même chose rêver d'un
moteur européen failli sont confrontés à
la même situation donc c'est la même
chose à un ralentissement en fête
mondiale delà de la croissance pac il y
en a plein de choses mais effet que le
coc ville continue explique on a une
sorte de copie de long économique en
fait c'est à dire que les échanges ont
pas repris comme avant et ça quand vous
avez moins dé change ça veut dire que
vous avez une barre enchérissement ça
assez naturelle des biens et puis
évidemment vous avez situation
géopolitique qui se tend et qui fait
qu'on est en train de voir sur le long
terme que les approvisionnements vont
pas être aussi facile l'énergie même
beaucoup plus cher pendant longtemps
tout çà çà çà çà père fusent dans toute
la chaîne de valeur et ça finit par
arriver on va très bien chez le
boulanger enfin l'une des plus chères on
sait pas exactement comment on va
pouvoir aujourd'hui c'est mon essence
est planté ce qu'il pourra faire les
graines l'année prochaine où tout ça va
forcément avoir un impressionnant terme
et ça peut aller jusqu'à l'emploi
puisque les entreprises seront peut-être
un peu moins optimiste pour l'avenir
s'appelle entre l'instant pour l'instant
c'est pas la surprise c'est que
l'investissement est plutôt en hausse
effectivement le seul point positif dans
tout certain racisme c'est quand même
l'emploi où on est par exemple pour les
cas depuis très longtemps en fait le
plein en passant on n'y est pas encore
cessé d'une crainte mathieu la
difficulté pour emmanuel macron en plus
c'est que les français ont pris
l'habitude une certaine façon d'avoir
été aidées afin d'être aidés en période
de crise et ça change quand même les
mentalités et à queue il ya eu un effort
social national qu'on a pu saluer au
monde la crise qu vide avec une forme de
nationalisation des salaires pour toute
une partie des secteurs d'activité des
aides aux entreprises qui étaient en
très grande difficulté et du coup se
retrouver en très grande difficulté pour
aujourd'hui des facteurs extérieurs
comme la crise en ukraine et voir un
gouvernement où un état qui ne viendrait
pas en être de tous ces gens
en grande grande souffrance en grand
danger ça serait incompréhensible du
point de vue de pillon pourquoi on l'a
fait il ya deux ans et pourquoi on ne
leur ferait pas la même si les causes
sont un peu sont un peu différentes
après il ya eu une vraie question à se
poser du côté des entreprises parce que
on est quand même en france un pays où
les salaires n'ont pas augmenté comme
ailleurs comme à l'étranger depuis
j'allais dire deux ans depuis la sortie
de la crise qu vide et même sur le long
terme si on prend depuis dix ans depuis
vingt ans les salaires on a un gros gros
retard français donc à un moment ça
c'est l'un des nôtres l'état ne peut pas
tout si on veut redonner du pouvoir
d'achat faut bien que les entreprises
mettent la main à la poche qu'elle
arrête pour une fois de dire qu elles
reconstituent leur marge et qu'elle ait
cédé la parole à olivier babeau là
dessus mais mais ça c'est un peu une
lapalissade ce que je dis mais c'est
l'un des moteurs de la grogne sociale
que vous suivez de près pour l'obs bien
sûr alors les les augmenter les salaires
mais aussi un problème c'est qu'ils
abordent ans et gil et jo des dents de
ces gens qui sont en qui sont mécontents
il ya aussi beaucoup de tout petits des
artisans des pistes des petits
employeurs en fait qui eux mêmes sont
son sont leur propre employeur et tous
et toute cette catégorie de personnes
des tirs des petits retraités
des beaucoup de femmes seules avec leurs
enfants qui même quand elles ont un
emploi qui peu à peu près même si on
augmente un peu ont des charges qui sont
absolument énorme et ce sont des gens
qui sont à 10 euros 20 euros près par
mois donc quand on comment faire quand
on a une inflation quand on a un os du
coup la villa qui va être absolument
phénoménale on se sent tous on va tous
arrivés avec des gens qui déjà ne s'en
sortent pas moi je moi j'ai eu comme je
n'oublie pas des gens qu'ils rencontrent
et qui qui pouvait parfois ne prendre
qu'un ou deux repas par jour parce que
il préférait en donner 3 leurs enfants
c'est quelque chose c'est pas pour faire
pleurer c'est une réalité les sit in à
libé d'ailleurs ce que vous disiez ce
qu'on le ressent déjà dans la
consommation s'avère que le moteur est
l'un des moteurs de la croissance en
france très clairement parce qu'il faut
faire des arbitrages la consommation est
en train de de baisser sur sur la
question des salaires je veux bien vous
entendre parce que c'est intéressant
dans le débat vous souvenez dans le
débat d'entre deux tours entre les
manades mac on est marine le pen c'était
l'un des axes sur lesquels le président
sortant a taclé la candidate du
rassemblement national en disant mais
vous n'avez pas la main sur sur les
augmentations de salaires du secteur
privé allemand en fait derrière ce sujet
il ya trois sujets parce que il ya les
salaires et les pensions il ya des
traitements n'a qu'à les fonctionnaires
ont été les salaires alors pour les
fonctionnaires vous augmenter d'un point
le point d'indicé 2 milliards de coût
pour le budget et donc ça ça va être une
demande qui arrive dès maintenant on dit
ah ça y est ça a été gelé pendant très
longtemps c'est un instrument celle de
régulation du poids de la fonction
publique sur pour l'état c'est à dire
que on revalorise pas comme ça ça allège
un tout petit peu c'est dire qu'en
faites-vous paupérisée la fonction
publique c'est ce qu'on a beaucoup fait
mais maintenant va y avoir une demande
forte pour que ça suive la deuxième
chose c'est les pensions les pensions
alors on peut effectivement indexé
augmenter massivement les pensions le
problème c'est que notre système il est
fermé c'est un système de transmission
donc vous avez les cotisations qui sont
des pourcentages de ce que les gens
touchent donc les gens pour l'instant
alors ça là il n'a pas augmenté donc les
cotisations sont les mêmes donc si vous
augmenter massivement les pensions ça
veut dire que déséquilibré ce système
avait pu en revient aux salaires vous
pouvez décider de certains salaires
c'est le salaire minimum vous pouvez
qu'est ce que vous faites vous
l'augmenter ça fait cas des gens qui
passent en dessous vous êtes obligés de
faire des négociations pour que une
partie revient en fait vous aplanissent
et la cour vous mettez de plus en plus
de gens à ce niveau minimum ils ont
d'ailleurs du mal à en sortir pour leur
carrière et à la fin a le vrai problème
si vous pouvez pas envie obliger les
chefs d'entreprises a augmenté salaires
c'est pas oui mais alors ce que disait
mathieu simon démographe pourquoi il
joue pas enfin entre guillemets je
reprends un peu la formule devrait-il
plus jouer jouer ce jeu quoi et et
augmenter les salaires peuvent-ils le
faire ils sont pour d'autres reprises
mais il entrevit des leçons il faut
regarder les entreprises au cas par cas
en fait malheureusement là encore il ya
une grande inégalité si vous êtes dans
un endroit où il ya des sites et des
compétences qui sont rares des métiers
en tension en fait ces gens ils sont
déjà bien payé est en fait il va de
mieux en mieux payé je vais vous dire
dire que ils vont pouvoir se revaloriser
ont gagné de plus en plus pour eux en
fait il va déjà pas de problème de
pouvoir d'achat le problème il est à
l'autre bout du spectre évidemment des
gens qui sont dans des situations alors
ça peut être parfois en tension
paradoxalement mais c'est des gens où il
ya toute façon des salaires qui sont
très bas et eux la revalorisation elle
va être beaucoup plus dur c'est pas
forcément la mauvaise volonté de la part
d un d entre eux pris un petit peu quand
même le secteur chr cafés hausse et
hôtellerie restauration pendant des
années il n'y a pas eu de de fortes
augmentations puis là il manque 300
mille personnes donc ils ont décidé
d'une augmentation de 15 à 18% donc
quand même
forcément à faire venir les gens non
c'est pas là c'est pas c'est pas le seul
argument non il y aura des augmentations
mais elles seront pas possible partout
donc en fait ça sera très très
inégalitaire si vous voulez être allé
très hétérogène je vous redonne la
parole tout de suite pablo pino villa
mais je propose d'entendre une réaction
des manades macron c'était vendredi
dernier bien conscient que même s'il l'a
emporté largement 58% une partie du pays
est à cran écoutez lancer le chantier
sur le pouvoir d'achat ou bien sûr
écoles et santé le bordeaux 2
pas forcément
parce que je suis français beaucoup de
choses qui peuvent être
justement décidé
et préparé pour mac est allé crédible
mais dont le voit bien c'est
coup d'envoi et puis un besoin d'un
abaissement généralisé un besoin
d'apaisement général il est joué vous
entendre les uns les autres là dessus et
pour commencer pablo pino dit qu'est ce
qu'est ce que ça veut dire dans la
stratégie du président de la république
donne moi je pense que c'est une
stratégie démocratique j'espère qu'il va
qui va s'écouter lui-même en fait qui va
appliquer lui-même ce qu'il dit vous
dites mais c'est dans la perspective des
législatives qui disent ah ah non non
non moi je pense que c'est dans la
perspective de son quinquennat afin
d'élire le quinquennat précédent a été
quand même très dur au niveau social les
rapports de force ont été
particulièrement violents mais et
violent physiquement à la fois du côté
des manifestants du côté de la police
dans les rapports de force syndicaux
étaient aussi très violent avec des
politique de la chaise vide quasiment
systématique notamment de la part de la
cgt donc il faut pour pour 8 il faut
huiler les rouages de la démocratie donc
il faut effectivement apaisé j'aimerais
revenir sur ce que vous disiez c'était
c'est tout à fait juste que vous avez
présenté sur les trois leviers à la fois
les pensions les les traitements et les
et des salaires mais je pense que si on
se place du point de vue de beaucoup de
françaises et de français et si ce ne
sera pas ce que vous disiez mathieu sur
le fait que finalement les français
s'étaient habitués à être aidée le
problème c'est que c'est ce qui s'est
passé par exemple pendant la crise du
coc vidé ce qui va pouvoir aussi se
passer pendant la la la crise de
l'ukraine avec l'augmentation du prix
d'énergie c'est que ceux qui vont gagner
il dira qu'ils vont gagner il y en a
d'autres qui vont perdre s'il ya des
gens qui ont vécu très durement la crise
du coc vide je pense notamment aux plus
jeunes à aux étudiants etc ça a été
excessivement dur pour eux et donc
entendre bon bah c'est bon on a
vachement dépenser d'argent pendant le
coc vide il ya eu çà d'un côté et d'un
autre côté il ya des on a on voit les
milliardaires on voit les chiffres ça
tourne sur les réseaux sociaux s'est dit
dans les médias les milliardaires se
sont énormément enrichis et c'est cette
différence en fait c'est 7 c'est cette
torsion en fait entre autres les deux
pôles qui au bout d'un an forcément de
crise peu la société et c'est ce qu'ils
lisent de se passer aussi dans la guerre
en ukraine parce qu'on dit à une
augmentation du prix de l'énergie et par
notamment là on parle du prix du gaz
même si le gaz russe représente que 17 %
de nos importations ça ça peut avoir un
impact fort sur ce qui va se passer en
france notamment à un hiver prochain
mais en vérité les plus riches les plus
riches des français et des françaises
ils vont pas le voir enfin ils vont à
peine le ressentir ces les plus pauvres
en fait c'est ce dont les logements sont
des passoires thermiques quant à leur
couper 2h06 y a quelqu'un qui habite
dans du dans un logement
takacs et d'effectuer au niveau de
l'isolation si on lui coupe le gaz
pendant deux heures ça va être une
catastrophe ça peut perdre 2,3 degrés en
l'espace de deux heures alors que le
bourgeois qui vit dans un appartement
isolé lui il n'y aura absolument aucun
problème il peut se permettre de ne pas
avoir dû dias tendait à priori c'est
plutôt les entreprises qui seraient
ciblés les premiers vraiment pas 104
consommation primaire de gaz
effectivement elle est pas l pas appris
à la consommation et le paradoxe olivier
babeau pardon de vous interrompre c'est
que la france est quand même un pays
très redistributeur d eux-mêmes avant
avant le quoi qu'il en coûte avant la
gestion des crises il faut toujours
rappeler cette étude de l'insee qui est
vraiment très intéressante sur le niveau
de vie des 10% extrême les dépenses dans
les pures origines % les les moins
riches et en fait avant redistribution
les deux moyennes vont de un à quinze
c'est le rapport de 20 à 15 après ray
distribution en prenant en compte les
services publics c'est de 1 à 3 ou un 4
c'est à dire qu'on est vraiment le
système le plus puissamment
redistributif et égalisateur si vous
voulez du du monde il faut s'en
féliciter
mais c'est mais c'est pas ressenti ce
n'est pas ressenti comme tel par angers
tigana disons que il faut toujours se
comparer un petit peu et voyagez souvent
on se rassure sur le système français et
puis on quand même on voit pas mal
d'avantagés aux états unis mais met donc
c'est ça c'est évidemment une un fait
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut se souvenir qui
veut pas dire que tout n'est pas qu'ils
ne l'aient pas tous les papillons pas
prêt mathieu on parle souvent d'un
troisième tour social est ce qu'il est
forcément inéluctable en tout cas quand
on en parle généralement il se produit
jamais c'est très très rare quand on dit
la rentrée sera chaude là on aura
toujours sociale
et elle est toujours chaude et quand on
dit qu'il sera chaude et plus
généralement pas plus lourdes comme ça
que ça pourquoi parce que les mouvements
sociaux ça ne se décrète pas c'est déjà
absolument pas les politiques qui
décrète vous souvenez 2017 jean luc
mélenchon promet plusieurs millions de
personnes dans la rue et un automne très
très chaud pour faire échec aux lois
travail aux ordonnances sur sur les
votre travail de nicole pénicaud c'est
un flop les ordonnances passe et il n'y
a pas non plus une révolution dans le
pays parce que ya pas deux il n'y a pas
de lieu de courroie de transmission
entre les politiques et la population
est-ce qu'il y en a une entre les
syndicats et la population même pas même
plus toujours parce qu'on sait bien que
les mouvements sociaux mais ils
répondent à d'autres préoccupations oui
quand il ya une réforme des retraites
qui toucherait à la sncf des [__]
bastion très syndiqués la wii un
syndicat peut mettre et aligner des gens
dans la rue on l'a vu quand il ya eu la
réforme des retraites a avorté d'edouard
philippe il ya eu des semaines entières
le rêve avec deux manifestations pour le
reste c'est beaucoup plus diffus qu'est
ce qui fait un mouvement social on ne
sait pas emmanuel a beaucoup travaillé
sur la question des gilet jaune voilà
typiquement un mouvement social qui
n'est que les syndicats échoue à
récupérer et nous a structuré que les
politiques échouent la même chose ar
cela a échoué à leur proposer un
débouché justement politique et ça donne
ça donne une explosion sociale et vraie
explosion sociale on ne les voit pas
venir elles surprennent tout le monde et
on n'arrive pas à les canaliser jeunes
et alors si on regarde les chiffres de
la mobilisation hier pour la fête du
travail moi j'étais sur les réseaux
sociaux joyet des réactions des ans
c'est historique c'est donc on est à
dire regardez ce que ce que ça donnait
donc il y avait selon les sources
évidemment préfecture de police d'un
côté
et cgt de l'autre entre 116000 et 210
mille personnes hier on a juste regarder
les années présidentielles parce que
c'est intéressant on voit qu'il ya cinq
ans c'était jusqu'à 280 mille personnes
en 2012 entre 316 et 750 mille personnes
là aussi bon on connaît bien le fond ça
tombe souvent dans l'entre-deux-tours
alors c'est ce que j'allais dire son
genou est ce que j'allais dire
effectivement les les cas précédents
alors 2002 on est dans la mobilisation
anti le pen père on a bien vu que ça
avait changé avec les années mais ça
c'est pas nouveau on a déjà analysé ici
mais effectivement tableau c'est la
différence c'est la date c'est à dire
que dans les cas précédents on était
avant la présidentielle il y avait un
effet mobilisateur plus important
d'après lui c'est absolument certain
mais après les raisons pour lesquelles
on a dit que le 1er mai d'hier oui
c'était hier était et est historique
c'était parce que moi ce que j'ai vu
c'est une adéquation très intéressante
finalement entre les revendications des
syndicats et finalement le débouché
politique offertes par cette potentielle
union de la gauche qui est en train de
se faire en ce moment c'est à dire que
quand vous lisiez j'ai lu le communiqué
de presse de l'intersyndicale
avec toutes les revendications qui
étaient étaient listés bon bah c'est bon
an mal an tout ce qui est présent dans
le programme de l'avenir en commun de
jean-luc mélenchon et à défaut enfin
dans les mêmes dans les autres dans les
autres programmes de la gauche et que
finalement
philippe martinez lorsqu'il était
interrogé le matin du dimanche 1er mai
sur une chaîne de télévision en fait il
était même pas il est déçu des nuits
sont pas très contents en fait que les
politiques prennent beaucoup de place en
fait dans leur manifestation syndicale
du 1er mai est là finalement ils
trouvaient ça assez logique et moi c'est
ça que je pense c'est pour ça que je
pense que dans les semaines à venir y
aura pas forcément de d'explosion
sociale précisément parce que cette
colère qui existe en france elles
trouvent un débouché naturel dans ce qui
est en train de se passer à à gauche et
du coup il ya les élections en le 12 et
du 19 juin prochain pour acquis qu'une
façon en fait d'exprimer cette colère je
vois un peu dubitative
je trouve ça très optimiste j'aimerais
ça je trouve ça fait longtemps que les
syndicats
finalement non plus ne tiennent plus
l'agenda de toutes ces crises sociales
et et du mécontentement de ces gens
qu'on retrouve dans la rue ou ailleurs
donc je vois là je suis un peu un peu
pessimistes voient ce que ce qui était
marquant encore aussi je trouve froid
msc cette violence qui aujourd'hui nous
semble banal tristement banale une
déflation sans violence et oui et enfin
la 1er mai il ya vingt ans il y avait
des familles des gens avec leurs gosses
et c'était populaire et c'était familial
et c'était festif aujourd'hui ça se
finit avec c'est encore le cas hier en
moi j'y étais
oui il ya toujours un effet loupe ou
c'est bien on exactement c'est comment
fonctionnent les médias c'était plutôt
embêtant mais là je mets pas de l'eau ce
qui a changé c'est que dans les cortèges
précédent le service aux restes de la
cgt c'était solide et oui mais hélas mes
envies mais là le
saisir la police alors qu'auparavant
c'est pas anodin ça c'est un problème
d'aujourd'hui se sont imposés dans des
tours de polissage son cortège n'y a pas
de débouchés politiques pour les black
blocks exactement muller façon que pour
le sien même temps on parle de centaines
sont annulées ou une partie des jaunes
sur lesquelles vous avez travaillé et un
autre débouché politique des jeunes et
leur ascendant
pas forcément la gauche
dans les dix jours que je connais la
montée mais bien aux gens tour alors
énorme bataille mais comme d'ailleurs
dans beaucoup d'endroits à ceux qui ont
voté le pen et ceux qui la prennent pas
ce pâle figure d'ailleurs ont appelé à
l'abstention j'ai jaune et se sont fait
lyncher cela les eaux sociaux mais ce
que j'ai la haine on va dire qu'il est
une énorme lassitude 1 de ce mouvement
la plupart l'a10 voilà on était le 1er
mai on arrête le manif en arène le cnt
on arrête ça y est donc là ils arrêtent
voilà mes mais il y a il y avait quand
même dans ce premier mais aussi beaucoup
de jeunes en colère vous en parlais tout
à l'heure je pense que voilà on sait pas
comment tout ça va se transformer comme
dit mathieu on a évidemment qu on ne
décrète pas une crise sociale après il
ya une désespérance il ya il ya
profondément dans certaines parties de
populations dont les jeunes et dont
c'est tout petit salaire un désespoir on
va parler des retraites vouliez
intervenir pour
la tragédie française c'est évidemment
la crise de corps intermédiaires dont
font partie les syndicats moi la
dernière grève dont je me souviendrai
mans c'était celle de 95 où j'étais
étudiant et pendant trois semaines j'ai
dû aller à vélo
pour étudier parce qu'il y avait zéro
métro et ça c'était cet esprit il
neigeait en plus et c'était ça a été
mais a depuis on faisait il ya ba jeu
n'ont jamais étudié bareille mai mais
est en fait depuis il n'y a plus
vraiment c'est vrai il ya beaucoup moins
de grèves les beaucoup de mouvements
sociaux de la même façon que
l'expression politique a déserté les
partis politiques l'expression des
revendications à déserter les canaux
habituels de manifestations et ils
prennent d'autres formes comme celle des
gilet jaune c'est une caractéristique
surprenante de notre époque qu'est ce
qui fait que du coup ses traits à ses
traits incontrôlable et puis
imprévisible parce que effectivement les
corps intermédiaires sont pas là pour
arriver à leur donner une expression
politique d'autres mais massa
l'institutionnel et autres
manifestations le complotisme chacun en
train de deux mois la gangrène et en
soit en souterrain c'est quelque chose
qui permette en train de gagner une
population extrêmement large donc c'est
une autre façon aussi de ceux de chasse
un autre oui même si cette crise et la
parole des lidd syndicaux elle est de la
même façon balayé par le complotisme la
parole de leaders politiques ou de
personnalités médiatiques quelle qu'elle
soit n'hésite pas n'hésite pas à dire
cgt collabos en permanence lorsqu'il
croise des militants de la cgt alors le
poids des syndicats justement va en
parler tout de suite avec marion vidéo
vous pouvez nous rejoindre marion à
propos de la réforme des retraites
rebond soir qu'est ce qui se prépare les
formes des retraites évidemment annoncé
par le candidat mcg effectivement ce
sera l'un des dossiers brûlants de
quinquennat macron 2 est évidemment dans
le cortège du 1er mai cette réforme
faisait partie des revendications on a
vu des pancartes qu'ils évoquaient on
rappelle que le président envisage de
reculer l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 65 ans contre 62 aujourd'hui
et qu'en dise effectivement les
syndicats et bien la plupart y sont
opposés s'il n'y a pas eu de
concertation à ce jour sur ce dossier un
front uni se dessine néanmoins dans un
communiqué commun publié le 1er mai fsu
sud solidaires et l'unsa évoquent leur
opposition au report de l'âge légal
voici d'ailleurs ce que disais à
dominique corona secrétaire général
adjoint de l'unsa parler des retraites
en parlant uniquement de l'âge légal ça
n'a aucun sens ça ne résout pas la
pénibilité l'employabilité des seniors
c'est bien trop réducteur et dogmatique
du côté de force ouvrière c'est la
méthode qui ne passe pas le secrétaire
général y verriez regrette que le
président n'ait pas évoqué ce projet de
réforme en amont avec les syndicats il
varie qui a d'ailleurs écrit au numéro
un des quatre autres confédérations de
salariés pour organiser ensemble leur
opposition à la réforme et quel est le
son de cloche du côté du premier
syndicat de france la cfdt et bien son
président laurent berger considèrent que
le système des retraites est à l'
équilibre en france et que cette réforme
est donc parfaitement inutile écoutez le
cdt n'est opposé au report de l'âge
légal retraite elle et elle ira à
discuter
l'amélioration qualitative du système
des retraites pour qu'ils soient plus
justes l'âge légal de départ en retraite
à 62 ans il faut y rester aujourd'hui je
suis très clair là dessus il faut
améliorer le système des autres seul
voix dissonantes la cftc elle favorable
à une réforme du système mais qui attend
d'en savoir plus sur l'âge de départ 64
65 sur la prise en compte des carrières
longues et de la pénibilité et écoutez à
ce propos cyril à chabanais le président
de la cftc on ne sait pas encore tout ça
c'est pas mis sur la table donc avant de
partir sur sur un front commun il faut
quand même avoir un peu plus un peu plus
de bill comme il n'y a pas d'urgence il
faut pas que ce système des retraites et
cette future réforme soit faite à la
va-vite soit fait par des ordonnances
soit faite éventuellement on a entendu
parler dans 49 3 non il faut laisser le
temps au dialogue social de discuter
c'est vraiment très important donc on
prend le temps et on prend le temps pour
faire une réforme juste et si cette
réforme les justes elle sera acceptée
quant au calendrier rien ne devrait
bouger d'ici les législatives puisqu'il
faut évidemment attendre de voir si le
président aura sa majorité ou non à
l'assemblée nationale pour mener à bien
cette réforme merci mario olivier babeau
et ce qui a effectivement besoin ou non
de cette réforme pour l'équilibré du
système
en fait la question est très complexe
mais pour dire les choses simplement
quand même oui alors on avait en 1960
68,3 vous allez 4 cotisant pour un
retraité aujourd'hui on doit être 1,8 je
crois cotisant pour un retraité
le leur avis ça tient jusqu'en 2030 oui
bah oui parce que bio on attend un
changement démographique et baby boomer
ont librement finir par mourir et en
allemand ça pas mal
mais
prévoir la mort des gens c'est terrible
mais on va tous mourir des soins de jour
non mais aujourd'hui on a une retraite
sur dix n'est pas financée savalli de
plus en plus loin en fait le plus
inquiétant c'est la baisse du taux de
remplacement c'est à dire c'est la
baisse de l'argent que vous avez par
rapport au dernier salaire et donc les
projections elles font que comme c'est
un système fermé il ya un moment donné à
ce qu'ils valent une poche à l'autre
c'est ce qu'on arrive à prendre on
prévoit que malheureusement ça soit de
plus en plus bas et on a on a un taux
qui est très bas par rapport à d'autres
pays à des pays on est à plus de 100 %
taux de remplacement si on touche plus à
la retraite qu'avant et nous on va de
plus en plus à l'est vers l'est ce que
50 45 % c'est quand même extrêmement bas
c'est à dire qu'il ya un appauvrissement
moment du passage à la retraite qui est
extrêmement fort donc posé les choses
simplement
on vit beaucoup plus longtemps il faut
travailler plus longtemps voilà alors
c'est vrai que ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
ya pas de problème sur la pénibilité
c'est tout à fait prévu et la 3ème sur
l'emploi des seniors parce qu'ils ont
encore faut-il que les ans le senior
arrivent à l'âge de la retraite pour
pouvoir la toucher et puis à la question
des minima évidemment de retraite mais
qui sont sa bien prévues dans 6 ce qui
est très clair c'est que depuis le début
il ya un problème de méthode c'est
qu'effectivement même si ils avaient dit
qu'il y avait eu la concertation c'est
ce qu'ils ont raté probablement un
moment de la première retraite avec
delevoye qui en plus est partie au
milieu et donc il va falloir s'ils
veulent remettre ça sur le métier
complètement changé la méthode ça me
paraît déjà pour l'instant pas super
bien juste une question sur différence
entre espérance de vie espérance de vie
en bonne santé ah bah c'est pas la même
chose pour l'espérance de vie la bonne
santé évidemment c'est en fonction de
critères que vous allez exigé en vain
que vous allez ainsi mais c'est beaucoup
moins élevé alors iranienne très très
grandes inégalités vous avec les hommes
vivent plus longtemps que les femmes
donc les femmes touchent plus longtemps
mais elles ont des retraites plus basse
parce qu'en général elles ont des
carrières qui sont différentes vous avez
des ouvriers qui meurt beaucoup plus tôt
évidemment que les cadres il ya plein à
60 ans les enseignants vivent très
longtemps et il faut croire que c'est un
métier qui concerne vous avez plein
plein d'inégalités à à plein de niveaux
en fonction de vos niveaux de vie de
métier
tableau oui moi je pense que jean la
question de l' équilibre du régime de
retraite c'est une fausse question
puisque d'ailleurs le corps à chaque
fois répondant tout ça fait le conseil
d'orientation
et il répond effectivement que c'est à
horizon 2030 façon il explique en gros
que leurs modèles à 10 ans il est
difficilement prédictible et à plus de
plus de dix ans c'est encore pire enfin
je veux dire il ya plein il ya plein
d'événements en fait qu'ils peuvent se
passe ça dépend de la tra exactement ça
dépend de la croissance ça dépend là on
a eu la crise du coc vite par exemple
vous imaginez bien que ça a changé
beaucoup de choses au niveau du
financement des du régime des retraites
moi je pense que c'est pas tant que ça
en fait qui intéresse emmanuel macron
c'est pas l'équilibré du régime de
retraite que le passage de 62 à 63 ans
en fait ça permet de faire travailler
les gens plus longtemps et donc en fait
de faire d'abonder en fait les caisses
de l'état pendant trois ans
supplémentaires parce que lorsque
lorsque vous travaillez trois ans vous
avez plus de vos cotisations en fait que
vous continuez à payer assez normalement
vous continuer aussi à le faire lorsque
vous êtes retraité à vos pensions de
retraite il ya aussi des cotisations
pour financer le budget de l'état est en
fête avec ça c'est sa façon à lui en
fait c'est l'argent qui va trouver à cet
endroit là donc il va se payer sur le
travail il va financer en fait tout le
restant parce que il a quand même des
choses à faire il n'a parlé de l'espace
il a parlé de la mer il a parlé de plein
de choses et c'est cela qui va aller le
chercher et en fait ça c'est une vision
amont et vacances donc c'est financer
les retraites c'est pour financer le
reste est exactement parce qu'il a des
réformes à financer j'entends ça sur sur
la formule qu'on a entendu tout à
l'heure dans ce sonore le le son n'était
pas très bon mais bref on l'a entendu et
mâcon qui dealent cette demande
d'apaisement des français moi ça me fait
penser aux jacques chirac réélu
avec jean marie le pen et qui du coup
est presque se condamne à l'immobilisme
voyez ce que je veux dire est ce que est
ce que c'est pas un risque politique qui
guette emmanuel macron
j'espère j'espère vraiment que contre
lui parle d'apaisement ils parlent pas
d'immobilisme et bien de changement de
méthode de gouvernance ce ce que
vraiment beaucoup attendent
il l'a reconnu lui-même qu'il avait
failli sur là dessus et et on sent bien
que dans cette société qui est sorti
quand même aussi très divisée cette
crise sanitaire
avec beaucoup de gens qui se sont ils
laissés pour compte mais sur le côté
économiquement ils ont été aidés mais on
a on a quand même eu 7 s'est fracturé
aussi de pas accident il ya une france
dans une france d'en bas qui plus que
jamais se regardent en chiens de faïence
on l'a vu avec cette colère entre à
l'occasion de va d'autre mélenchon et le
libéral des des gens qui réussissent que
représentent les manuels macron comment
réconcilier ces deux france je pense
qu'on en est on en est vraiment là
aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai je laissais
si on se compare à d'autres pays si on
parle de cette crise que vides la france
à aider ses concitoyens comme peu de
pays l'ont fait au monde et pourtant il
ya cette grogne sociale dont on parle ce
que je veux dire n'y a pas forcément le
le bénéfice politique pour l'exécutif
d'avoir dépensé autant d'argent moi je
connais par exemple au japon les
entreprises elles ont pas du tout aidé
comme les anglais étaient aidés comme
les entreprises françaises peuvent
l'être ça veut dire quoi ça veut pas
dire des chefs d'entreprise qui
s'enrichissent moi ça veut dire des gens
qui se retrouvent au chômage que les
choses soient soient claires et il n'y a
pas de bénéfice politique pour l'instant
en tout cas non à ce que la défiance
reste très importante parce qu'il ya ce
2 de la même façon qu'on a senti par
exemple la colère effectivement encore
monter des jeunes par rapport au mieux
mon journal on a tous senti je pense
même jeu
propre famille de nuitées de fracture
entre des jeunes qui disait vous êtes en
train de de vous payer notre planète
notre avenir
et et et macro candidats des vieux en
faveur on a entendu ça aussi dont il ya
sociologie des vins tout ça donc c'est
s'est fracturé elles sont pas que dans
le fait de recevoir de l'argent pour une
entreprise françois bayrou se dit
favorable au référendum pour la réforme
des retraites mathieu est ce que c'est
c'est peut-être la porte de sortie d'
emmanuel macron sur ce sur ce dossier là
bon courage oui parce que bon courage
parce que nous restions poser la
question directement au comment on pose
une question sur les retraites on peut
faire l'augmentation de la durée légale
mais là si on en croit en tout cas
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion basse
après quand même pas très populaire
après je pense que pour le coup ça se
prête plus déjà une concertation et
c'est de construire une réforme commune
alors avec c'est à dire tous les gens de
bonne volonté en gros chaque
gouvernements successifs a fait il ya
une espèce de consensus dans la classe
politique qui voulait que chaque
gouvernement fasse un petit bout de la
réforme delà des retraites en dans la
perspective que le dénoncer tout à
l'heure à l'os et qui inquiétait de
d'allonger d'allonger la durée légale et
d'allonger parce qu'on considérait que
le fait de le système était plus
supportable et puis à des gouvernements
qui n'ont rien fait mais emmanuel macron
n'a pas fait la sienne est donc là pour
le coup ça vaudrait le coup de
rassembler les forces politiques les
forces syndicales les forces
associatives s'il faut inventer des
choses de démocratie participative de
convention citoyenne c'est peut-être là
il faut le faire parce que c'est un
débat structurant pour les prochaines
années mais on peut pas se payer le luxe
d'avoir une réforme qu'ils fassent 60 %
de mécontents qui bloquent le pays et
surtout qu'ils ne soient pas partagées
l'idée c'est quand même de préserver le
système c'est pas forcément de s'en
mettre plein les poches à court terme et
après juste sur ce qu'on disait il ya un
indicateur qui est le chômage n'a jamais
autant baissé et c'est le sien n'est pas
mis au crédit de madame macron hessel
n'est même pas mis au crédit de est ce
que la france va mieux parce
qu'aujourd'hui trouver un job c'est plus
forcément alors évidemment que ça va
mieux mais on voit tout de suite les
difficultés quand on trouve un job bas
salaires qui nous parce qu'on a du mal à
vivre un as du mal à boucler une femme
moi c'est plus la planche de salut comme
ça pouvait l'être encore il ya quand
même de quelques années la gamme de plus
en plus de travailleurs pauvres de gens
qui n'a en fait ne ne font pas 35 heures
par semaine et du coup qui sortent des
chiffres du chômage et ceux là
effectivement il on a un boulot mais
enfin qui ne leur paraît pas de de vivre
dignement donc voilà je sais pour un peu
genre modéré genre nous notre
empressement à trouver que les chiffres
du chômage sont sont excellents on
termine là dessus merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé c'est parce que
vous avez
trouvé un job aujourd'hui c'était pas
forcément l'assurance de vivre ça allait
et 20 du corps etc on vous devine encore
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat